[Musique]
l'air de paris n'est pas exactement ce
qu en disent les chances et les
pancartes les plus optimistes ne peuvent
rien contre les fumées de la capitale
sur laquelle chaque année nous disent
les experts retombe 13000 tonnes de
poussière rançon du progrès l'atmosphère
des grandes villes est chaque année un
peu plus pollués il a bien fallu se
pencher sur le problème
c'est ainsi que chaque jour des équipes
vont prélever des échantillons d'air
dans les différents quartiers
c'est ainsi que les laboratoires
spécialisés analyse en l'air que nous
respirons ont pu jeter la larme
paris est en train de s'intoxiquer paris
c'est à dire la foule parisienne et les
cheminées des usines ne sont pas seuls
en cause
il ya aussi les voitures dont les pots
d'échappement éjecte en particulier avec
l'oxydé de carbone se base aux 3/4
pyrène au nom barbare et qui est très
cancérogènes paris c'est à dire aussi
les arbres qui dépérissent sur les
avenues et qu'il faut remplacer
grâce aux prises d'air permanente c'est
petit entonnoir insolite apparu sur les
toits de paris
on a établi les diagrammes d'une journée
de respiration parisienne le
noircissement du filtre par les déchets
qui est intensif en soirée serait nulle
la nuit sans leur de cuisson du
boulanger jusqu'au matin louis il
reprend il devient donc urgent de
limiter les causes de pollution de l'air
qui menacent nos poumons dans tracks
hausse et autres facteurs pathogènes
sinon il faudra un jour nous résoudre à
d'ennuyeuse extrémité il faudra
peut-être changer le style de notre
oeuvre
et le moins qu'on puisse dire c'est que
même les présentations de mode ne
gagneront pas
[Musique]